so of all of the theories out there
about how han can return to this
franchise is there anyone in particular
that was just
the wildest that caught your eye and
made you laugh
hmm that's a good question barry uh
i think the
most ridiculous
and it's not ridiculous for hollywood
but that han had some evil twin brother
and he came back
you know maybe you know instead of long
hair he has you know like a shaved head
or something like that
and
i don't know how that would work and i
don't think i would be interested in
doing that but that that was kind of
goofy you know i'm like what he had an
evil brother like he was just hanging
out somewhere right makes no sense a
little bit but just to play around with
that yeah if that is what wounds up
happening and you got to take a real
swing a big swing with han's brother
what would be a quality that maybe
you've never been able to tap into in a
character before that you would want
that character to have yeah you know i
would love to
play
some type of
physical handicap like you ever see
daniel day-lewis is my left foot yes
something like that you know i don't
know if that character would fit in the
fast and furious world because he needs
both feet to drive and work his the
clutch and stuff but yeah something like
that i would love you know like some
type of maybe
like blindness some type of handicap
like physical handicap right i'm a big
believer that anyone could fit in this
franchise yeah yeah we'll see we'll see
that'd be cool all right so now going
back to the reality of the situation
here you know justice for han was a
really big deal i'm sure you were very
excited to return to the franchise but
when you do something like that you
really need to justify it story-wise so
when those conversations started
happening was there anything that made
you say to the folks in charge like i
want to come back but
this quality has to be in the character
or it has to be done this way so it
feels realistic that's a great question
perry you know i think if it was a
another director i never worked with
before
i didn't have the history i have with
justin you know those conversations
would have been very hard
and it probably it might have never
happened right because how do you trust
you know a character that's so beloved
to someone that didn't grow up with it
right or didn't wasn't there from the
foundation
and in many ways you know we started our
career together justin and i and we
started this character together right so
you know the conversation's always been
organic over the years of like what if
what if and how are we going to do this
and justin being so precious with the
han character you know if anyone was
going to take care of it it was going to
be him right so i mean i tell people
justin is more like han than i am in
real life so you know i think he knows
the character maybe sometimes better
than i do with that in mind over the
course of all the fast films you've been
in is there any particular moment where
maybe you were having a tough time
nailing a scene and justin who had such
a good understanding of that character
gave you a direction that pulled
something out of you that you might not
have been able to access yourself yeah
you know when i went back to fast nine
it it was many years since i you know
went back into han shu so my cadence was
it was different you know the way i
think i was anticipating too many things
especially like forcing things with like
activity like even the snacks right like
it was more of a gimmick it became a
gimmick right because everyone
associates you know snack with han where
before you know it was a choice as an
actor to make sure that i had an
activity while i'm observing
and that's where you know developing and
growing with a director over the years
you know you're able to have that
shorthand and so you know there were
times where i felt like i wasn't really
sure where han was going and even my
cadence was a little off and then you
know we would talk about like you know
you know why is he here you know who is
han like you know how is he seeing the
world what are those snacks for what are
those tools for right so
yeah just for fun let's say someone out
there wants to craft a
han food basket
what would you put in that basket
so every snack every dry snack every
chip needs to have a cheese flavor to it
some type of cheddar
um
and then everything needs to have kind
of a certain density where you can it's
like the density of like a peanut like
that way it's perfect to kind of be able
to toss into your mouth right
and you can kind of play with it rattle
around like dice in your hand so there's
a certain there's a certain weight and
size to
that's the the snacks in that basket all
right make sense now we can now we can
make it a a han and a you basket a
basket that reflects you as well what
are you throwing in what's like the type
of thing that you snack on to pass the
time in between exactly what i just said
perfect marriage right there yeah
all right going to something specific
said in the movie so
we know that there's a magic trick
involved in terms of uh han survival i
think he says something like pretty neat
magic trick to mr nobody yeah we know
the magic trip trick happens and he
survives but what is what is the magic
trick specifically that's a you know
you're you're i'm sure
you're the type of
uh audience member that a magician never
wants to meet like you can't
you can't tell
the secret that's why it's called magic
i can't tell you how that happened i
haven't have to wait till past him i
have that with magic tricks i do it with
backstory when i fall so hard for a
character i want to know every single
ounce of the road map that got them to
this particular point yeah i wish i
could tell you what that magic trick is
but to be honest with you perry i have
no idea what that trick is i respect
that thank you so much thanks barry